dr karl weiss bonsoir alors on a eu des
nouveaux chiffres aujourd'hui comme on a
dépassé un seuil des 1000 décès au
québec je voulais vous remonterez le
nombre de décès par million d'habitants
si on compare le québec et d'autres pays
bien sûr que l'histoire n'est pas
terminée mais ça vaut la peine de
s'arrêter mais je veux vous lumière
là-dessus l'ontario 46 l'allemagne 58 le
québec 122 tout près des états unis et
la france beaucoup plus élevés l'espagne
également
où vous en êtes dans votre réflexion sur
le nombre de morts au québec par rapport
au reste du canada docteur qu'on ne
maîtrise pas la situation quand
l'adresse du canada une évidence même on
a beaucoup plus de décès ça fait déjà
plusieurs semaines que c'est comme ça on
a quand même bien fait il faut quand
même le dire sur l'aspect au niveau
hospitalier notre nom de tir et de
personnes hospitalisées aux soins
intensifs est quand même relativement
stable mais c'est clair que l'épidémie a
frappé le québec beaucoup plus fort et
la structure peut être au niveau des ch
et celle des hauts niveaux de la gestion
de certains aspects a fait qu'au québec
on est deux on a eu une augmentation
très importante de la mortalité
malheureusement dans notre population
gériatrie et on a des chiffres qui se
passe qui ressemble beaucoup aux etats
unis quand on se compare en population
plutôt que le reste du canada qui a
tendance à ressembler beaucoup plus aux
pays qui ont des beaucoup moins je me
dirais deux cas même à l'intérieur du
canada l'ouest on dirait un très très
bien réussi parce que si vous regardez
l'alberta puis la colombie-britannique
ça va très bien l'ontario est dans une
situation un peu plus intermédiaire
certainement parce que ce qu'est ce
qu'est le québec qu'il était mais qui
est vraiment la province qui se
démarquent comme étant celle avec une
épidémiologie et une cour beaucoup plus
agressifs que les autres
et malheureusement on doit maintenant
faire les efforts pour essayer de
diminuer ces courants voulait aplatir
mais on n'est certainement pas encore
rendu un autre sommet en un an tort je
pense du chemin à faire qu'il peut
avant de contrôler aussi la situation
dans les sièges à celle des docteurs
j'ai vu passer sur cnn tout à l'heure
puis je voulais avoir votre avis parce
que le nombre vous imaginez pas le
nombre de gens qui nous écrivent encore
sur la crue chloroquine qui serait un
médicament miracle est où là il ya un
autre étude mais de qui n'est pas et ne
sera pas la dernière mais qui ne va pas
dans la bonne direction je crois bon
alors il faut savoir il faut savoir
interpréter cette étude d'avant c'est
une étude c'est comme toutes les études
en médecine et je suis pas là pour
donner un coup sûr comment retenir une
étude en médecine du tout mais cette
étude là ça a été fait chez les vétérans
aux états unis via trois groupes qui ont
été faits la chloroquine enfin hydroxy
chloroquine hydroxy chloroquine avec
l'asie trois missiles et un groupe avec
pad hydroxy chloroquine mais peut-être
de l'astronomie si ce qu'on sait dans
cette étude là ce qui semble ressortir
avec toutes les limites de l'étude c'est
que la chloroquine tout seul ne serait
pas un très bon médicament
par contre ce qui semble aussi peut-être
ressortir de cette étude là c'est que
laissent trop micinn est un médicament
qui pourrait avoir un certain bénéfice
est là il faut que je fasse très
attention à ce que je lis mais ça
l'étude n'a pas été fait pour ça mais
l'étude a définitivement montré que
hydroxyque le rocking tout seul dans une
forme d'étude ce n'est pas une étude
comme on fait habituellement mais qui
est une étudiante fait pour l'état
actuel des choses et là l'urgence des
choses
cette étude démontre que la chloroquine
tout seul hydroxy chloroquine n'a pas
d'effets bénéfiques en tout cas évident
à l'état actuel des choses la seule
chose qu'il faut regarder c'est que
l'instrument issing par contre st y
aurait eu un bénéfice à la donnée par
rapport à d'autres ça c'est une étude
n'a pas évalué ça mais au moins ça donne
une certaine réponses à des questions
vont se poser et je veux pas rentrer
dans les détails d'une étude parce qu'il
ya plein de nanas n'est en fait mais
souvent nous nous donnons à nos réunions
médicales en premier tout comme ça on a
décortiquons regarde où toutes les
limites qu'on peut avoir c'est pas
l'objectif mais oui la chloroquine tout
seul ne sent pas avoir un effet positif
globalement bons mais on est quand même
un peu un peu plus avancé
la direction de la santé publique
recommande une distanciation on l'a
beaucoup dit de 2 m la stm recommande un
mètre et les transporteurs aériens
oblige le port du masque
c'est une question du public que je vous
lis la distanciation
est ce un ou deux mètres et ethel
remplaçable dit elle en se couvrant le
visage autrement dit la question du mas
qui revient si j'ai un masque est-ce que
je peux m'approcher un peu plus parce
que dans les transports en commun semble
difficile de ne pas s'approcher
la réponse courte est devenu de plus en
plus clair ça fait déjà des semaines que
je pense on m'avait posé la question
puis j'ai dit le port du masque
universelle doit être commandé à
l'échelle du québec comme un diable
comme il est actuellement recommandé
partout dans les autres pays occidentaux
en aura pour en maintenant de plus en
plus en amérique du nord
il ya d'autres pays qui ont adopté le
port du masque obligatoire depuis
longtemps la vue singapour israël et
c'est donc le mas tout seul c'est pas la
panacée il comprendre ça mais le mas
associées à d'autres mesures
et il faut qu'il faut arrêter aussi de
dire le lavage des mains uniquement ou
le mas uniquement va aider les gens
c'est l'ensemble de ces mesures là c'est
ce qu'ont anglais on appelle un bandeau
ça veut dire que quand par exemple on a
eu des problèmes avec le clostridium
difficile
on a pris un ensemble de mesures qui ont
réduit les taux d'infection de la même
façon si on veut limiter les problèmes
reliés à cette endémie oui le la rage
demain c'est très très important
la distanciation social ça a
probablement avoir la joue et le fait de
porter un masque
associé aux autres mesures a un rôle à
jouer l'asp et étiquettes respiratoires
de ne pas tousser à la phase d ordre de
tousser dans son coude et ses terrasses
a un rôle à jouer mais probablement
c'est quand vous mettez tout ça ensemble
que vous avez le cocktail parfait pour
essayer de minimiser l'impact de lakovic
19 dans l'attaqué relation alors vous
nous dites pourquoi se priver de cet
outil là parmi les parmi les autres sans
oublier les autres consignes bien sûr
je saute à la question 4 je suis
étudiante en sciences biologiques et
j'écoute dr weiss tous les jours
est-ce possible que le virus se loge
dans le système nerveux et si oui
pourrait-il sylogis à long terme et
causer une infection qu'il est sûr
j'irai plus tard j'aime alors c'est une
bonne question c'est ce qu'on appelle
des virus ou neuro trope comme un peu de
vih qui peut aller dans un sanctuaire
alors là je vais répondre en deux
parties c'est un virus qui peut donner
qui peut donner une virémie stade y est
c'est un virus qui paraît dansant puis
on le voit il se distribuaient un petit
peu partout alors il peut probablement
aller dans le système nerveux parce
qu'il ya eu des descriptions de
problèmes neurologiques l'associer avec
ce virus là mais c'est un phénomène
plutôt rare excepté l'anoci et donc le
vsav et la perte du goût la perte de
l'odorat
mais habituellement cet instinct virus
d'une époque qui ne va pas donner des
problèmes majeurs au niveau du système
nerveux ce qu'on appelle des
encéphalites ou de ce genre de maladie
là où même déménagé de vira donc mais
oui pareil dans le système nerveux
il va pas souvent dans le système
nerveux excepté pour la noce me donc la
perte de goût la perte de l'odorat est
ce qu'il va pouvoir se subsister comme
le vih à long terme dans le système
nerveux central et revenir un jour la
réponse est non c'est pas ce type de
virus très bien dr weiss vous tenez la
route salon la la la la mort de morale à
l'hôpital neuf
on dit que c'est sous contrôle les
hôpitaux bien sûr mais il ya quand même
beaucoup de boulot dans les hôpitaux
désignés comme le montre la main oui
énormément de boulot parce que tout le
monde met la main à la pâte
il faut souligner le travail de tout le
monde dans cet hôpital psy je vous dirai
si c'était pas tout le monde qui mettait
la main à la pâte
on serait pas capable de débuter on va
dire la casse ici et là et puis moi j'ai
énormément d'admiration pour tous les
gens travaillent avec moi
merci les travailleurs de la santé au
grand complet sur un bon souligné dr 20
et c'est toujours un plaisir merci
beaucoup à très bientôt veulent croire
et au revoir